here's a flood water started gushing
into Teresa Mickey tires home it was
when cyclone edye struck central
Mozambique in March one wall collapsed
then another gate she ran and climbed
this tree to escape the rising torrent
her sister and her two small children
climbed this one she saw them washed
away when it collapsed was Elijah for I
was very sad because my sister was gone
that night I stayed in the tree crying
the next day people came in a can you to
rescue us eventually we found their
bodies this tents now Theresa's home
hundreds of people were killed by two
cyclones that struck Mozambique earlier
this year thousands are still in camps
that's where they're meant to vote in
Tuesday's presidential election the
people here have gathered to register
for food handouts the Cyclones affected
areas where many people have
historically voted for the political
opposition rights groups say many won't
be able to vote because voting cards
were washed away and haven't been
replaced the political opposition say
the ruling freely no party have used
humanitarian assistance to campaign for
votes
it was the port city of Beira where the
first cyclone made landfall the city's
mayor is now running for president he
leads a growing opposition party called
MDM we met him campaigning in a remote
village that seven months ago was under
water he's not happy with the
government's response the iva saying
that you if we don't vote for us if you
don't spend your vote for us you won't
get the foot so that's what they're
doing and that is a very bad but I'm
worried because the international
community is watching and they're not
doing anything the Cyclones ripped
through rose and washed away bridges
many of which have now been repaired the
ruling freely my party says its recovery
program has been a success it promises
to continue if it stays in power and it
denies foul play that's not true take
the humanitarian aid and give it to the
population is that the case that's not
true humanitarian aid was distributed in
front of the international community
election season might bring handouts and
promises from politicians but most
cyclone victims like Teresa lived in
grinding poverty before the storms and
since an election won't change that
Malcolm Webb al-jazeera
teeka Mozambique